reprise partielle du trafic aérien et
maritime avec la corse violents
incidents ce soir à bastia la partie
bradfer gouvernement syndicats
continuent la grogne des personnels
hospitaliers
manifestation à paris le mouvement de
grève national a été assez peu suivie
nouvelles inculpations d'homme politique
dans la sphère des fours structure du
sud-est dont celle de jean pierre roux
l'ancien maire d'avignon cambodge la
renaissance des campagnes leurs
reportages de nos envoyés spéciaux
trop crabe de la ratp déclare la guerre
aux tagueurs ses jeunes fans de
graffitis qui lui coûte si cher à
monsieur bonsoir les liaisons
s'améliorent entre la corse et le
continent
mais la situation se soit reste bien
confuse les aéroports et les ports sont
réouverts à bastia et à calvi fermé
ajaccio et la corse du sud est toujours
bloquée la grève générale du secteur
public continuent à bastia ce matin
quelques 3500 fonctionnaires avaient
manifesté dans le calme ce soir c'est la
bagarre à bastia françoise joly les
grilles de la préfecture de bastia une
nouvelle fois mise à mal par des
manifestants furieux il est 17h30
ils viennent d'apprendre que la réunion
prévue demain entre le directeur de la
fonction publique et les syndicats ne
sera pas l'objet d'ouverture de
négociations nous n'avons eu aucun
contact officiel avec le gouvernement
les seules informations c'est bien la
presse que les indices qui y est tout ce
que nous savons nous l'avons appris par
nos fédérations respectives
donc nous ne pouvons pas accepter ce
qu'on nous propose à savoir venir à
paris pour établir un ordre du jour sur
les tables rondes à venir
sur les négociations rien sur des
mesures concrètes pour les salariés
vous avez très bien compris cela veut
dire que nous n'aurons pas à paris si on
me le propose le lanceur d'engins
volants
quelques instants plus tard le presser
reçoit une délégation de responsables
syndicaux ils leur précisera que les
négociations devraient s'ouvrir mais pas
avant la fin de la semaine prochaine
dans le cadre des tables rondes de
michel rocard
si la cgt reconnaît que le gouvernement
a fait un pas elle refuse toujours de se
rendre à paris
les autres syndicats et sont moins
tranchées mais ce soir à bastia c'est la
violence qui a pris le dessus avec des
affrontements de plus en plus dure entre
3 de l'ordre et manifestants les
syndicats unanimes donc attendent la
mort ce d'une négociation avec les
représentants du gouvernement mais à
paris on voit les choses différemment
gérard leclerc et ce n'est plus une mère
c'est un océan d'incompréhension ce soir
entre la corse et le continent vient de
le voir sur la date de la véritable
négociation que le gouvernement renvoie
en fin de semaine prochaine
on le voit plus encore sur le fond deux
des revendications les corses ne
démordent pas d'une compensation
salariale à la vie chère sous forme de
primes d'insularité notamment or le
gouvernement ne veut pas entrer dans
cette logique
au nom des grands principes ce serait
contraire à la continuité territoriale
qui veut faire de la corse un
département comme les autres et plus
prosaïquement pour des questions de sous
le gouvernement a déjà beaucoup lâché
aux enseignants aux hospitaliers le
moment est venu de mettre le holà
s'il veut tenir l'inflation et boucler
un budget 90 qui s'annonce explosif les
corses n'ont pas encore obtenu leur
prime d'assiduité que déjà d'autres
fonctionnaires envisage des indemnités
de chauffage dans le nord ou de
résidences dans les grandes villes
michel rocard compte encore sur sa
méthode il veut amener la discussion sur
les problèmes économiques de fond de la
corse quitte à lâcher in extremis
quelques indemnités de transport aux
fonctionnaires et il joue sur le temps
le pourrissement et la relative
neutralité des nationalistes un pari
cette fois hautement risqué dans une île
qui peut à tout moment basculer de
l'exaspération à l'explosion et françois
je lis sûrement nous fera parvenir
d'autres informations dans le courant de
ce journal automobiliste garé à vos
points voilà quinze ans qu'on en parle
15 ans pour la journ parce qu'il est
complexe et coûteux à m
mais cette fois aussi par est la bonne
le ministre des transports michel
delbarre al'intention d'après françois
de présenter à l'assemblée nationale dès
la prochaine session le projet du fameux
permis de conduire à points a permis à
capital risque en quelque sorte comme
nous l'expliquent dominique verdeilhan
près d'un million de permis de conduire
sont délivrées par an dans le même temps
deux millions de procès verbaux sont
dressés pour infraction but du permis à
points réprimer les récidivistes
avec ce nouveau papier rose le
conducteur disposera d'un quota d'une
dizaine de points toute infraction
mettant en cause la sécurité entraînera
le retrait d'un certain nombre de points
la perte du capital obligera le
conducteur à repasser son permis
tous les trois ou cinq ans les compteurs
seront remis à zéro difficultés du
projet de loi déterminer combien une
infraction vaudra de points retirés et
ce afin que ce permis à points est
l'effet dissuasif recherché ce permis à
points doit sanctionner
que d'aider les infractions je veux dire
à risque élevé
si je peux c'est à dire l'alcool c'est à
dire la vitesse c'est à dire le problème
des gens qu'ils mettent pas leur
ceinture de sécurité
ce document n'entrera en vigueur que
lorsque les 30 millions de permis de
conduire seront informatisées comme
c'est le cas ici en allemagne
aujourd'hui en france seulement 10%
d'entre eux sont entrés dans
l'ordinateur
en 1992 tous les conducteurs devraient
donc posséder ce nouveau document mais
ceux qui ont déjà leur permis n'auront
pas leur passé les pouvoirs publics
espèrent que cette nouvelle mesure fera
chuter le nombre de victimes sur les
routes comme ce fut le cas déjà dans de
nombreux pays mais nous avons en tout
cas trois ans pour nous préparer au
nouveau système
le temps donc d'informatiser les les
permis de conduire délivrés en france
jusqu'ici la viande aux hormones
continue d'être produites en quantité
industrielle c'est un véritable trafic
juteux pour les fournisseurs comme pour
les éleveurs
on mesure son ampleur au réseau que les
gendarmes de clermont ferrand viennent
de démanteler dans le puy de dôme
quelque cent mille bêtes auraient été
traitées aux anabolisants au fil des
années dans la région
isabelle staes nous en dit plus vendeurs
d'aliments pour bétail une couverture
honorable pour un trafiquant
d'anabolisants dans cette propriété de
l'allier hendrix ne faisait fructifier
son commerce il est aujourd'hui
incarcéré
placé sous contrôle judiciaire son
épouse affirme ne rien comprendre à la
faire pourtant depuis huit ans cet
éleveur vendait des substances
interdites à ses clients dans 15
départements
la marchandise a été livrée dans des
sacs de nourriture l'existence du trafic
n'a pas vraiment surpris dans le milieu
d'élevage
la rumeur circulait depuis que ça va
être interdite
ils ont légalement quoi alors vous en
pensez quoi vous deux
de ce trafic bon je dis que c'est pas
une bonne chose pour pour l'élevage
bovin français et
c'est une concurrence déloyale
un trafic très lucratif il aurait
rapporté plusieurs millions de francs à
ses auteurs les gendarmes ont saisi une
quantité importante de produits prohibés
ce stock est estimé à 400 mille francs
difficile de déterminer le nombre exact
de bêtes piqué il en aurait au moins
cent mille tous les animaux contrôlé
positif soit par la présence de résidus
soit par la présence de traces sont
systématiquement retirés de l'avant
sommation circuit finisse avec harry
sage pour l'instant 30 éleveurs ont
reconnu avoir utilisé des anabolisants
200 autres doivent être interrogés
restent à remonter la filière point de
départ présumés de ce trafic à
laboratoire en belgique
assurons-nous l'utilisation de tels
produits est illicite
mais elle n'entraîne pas nécessairement
de risque pour le consommateur
simplement on est trompé sur la
marchandise c'est ce que nous explique
jean-pierre mitigé une petite dose de 60
mg et votre/vos gonflera peu à peu de 20
kg gains supplémentaires pour
l'agriculteur de 600 à 2000 francs par
bête mais pour le vendeur un litre de
produit à 10000 francs rapporte 500 fois
plus 5 millions de francs c'est très
important ça semble un peu oui les à
vous allez me dire mais à la drogue
c'est un peu la place à la dernière
grosse prise c'était dans le nord à
l'origine un libraire marchand
d'aliments pour bétail un simple
comparses
mais au delà on trouve les grosses
filière avec leurs passeurs on cite le
cas d'un laboratoire de hollande
officielle en semaine et qui fabrique
les dimanches 10 mille litres
d'anabolisants par mois pour le sud de
l'europe
au sommet de la chaîne on va trouver des
laboratoires des fabricants qui par leur
chimie soit fabrique effectivement
officiellement ces produits là mais ont
une production supérieure au cul qui
viendra alimenter les filières soient
des chimistes qui dans des laboratoires
clandestins vont également fabriqué mais
c'est un anabolisant seul moyen de
contrôler le cheptel des agriculteurs
des prélèvements analysés en laboratoire
regardez ces taches de couleurs détecte
une présence d'hormones ou encore par
prélèvement dans les abattoirs tout
d'infractions relevées l'an dernier
seulement 3% des cas mais il y a
l'habitude avant 1988 certaines hormones
étaient autorisées c'est bruxelles qui a
tout interdit pour éviter aux
consommateurs d'acheter de l'eau au prix
de la viande journée nationale de grève
dans les hôpitaux aujourd'hui une grève
assez peu suivie d'après le ministère de
la santé qui à n'en soit 2 6% de
grévistes à paris plusieurs catégories
de personnels hospitaliers étaient
pourtant encouragé par leur syndicat et
leur coordination rappeler leur grogne
et quelques 15 cents manifestants se
sont réunis ce matin devant le ministère
au moment où le conseil supérieur de la
fonction publique hospitalière examinait
le statut de certaines catégories de
personnel
les revendications de statut de salaires
de conditions de travail qui sont
martelés depuis des semaines maintenant
par toutes sortes professionnels de la
santé des chefs de clinique aux
infirmières en passant par les sages
femmes ou les techniciens de radiologie
ses revendications aboutissent en fait
dans la réalité quotidienne au même
problème comment gérer un hôpital quand
l'interlocuteur unique et l'état c'est
ce que daniel duigou et maryse richard
ont constaté à l'hôpital de pontoise
cet énorme dossiers sous les bras du
nouveau directeur de l'hôpital de
pontoise c'est son budget 89 60
milliards de centimes
un véritable casse tête les trois quarts
servent à payer les 2300 employés sont
en augmentation et chaque année
inférieure au taux d'inflation
enfin il ne tient absolument pas compte
de la poussée démographique de la ville
nouvelle
sept mille habitants de plus chaque
année ce corset budgétaire a bien sûr un
avantage
il impose la chasse au gaspillage mais
surtout il a un inconvénient il empêche
l'hôpital d'embauché et d'acheter de
nouveaux matériels
plus grave chaque année 600 malades sont
transférés sur d'autres hôpitaux et
parmi ces malades ceux atteints par le
sida
le traitement du sida avec la zte et les
médicaments qui lui sont associées coûte
à l'heure actuelle cent mille francs par
malades et parents
notre budget ne permet pas à la règle
elle prononcera pour sortir de l'impasse
le directeur voudrait mettre en place
une nouvelle stratégie d'abord
rentabiliser informatique plus
comptabilité analytique égale meilleur
calcul des coûts de chaque traitement
selon chaque pathologie
deuxième priorité négocié avec l'état
des contrats pour un budget exceptionnel
l'objectif c'est développer les
nouvelles technologies en radiologie
cancérologie biologie une nouvelle
stratégie qui serait celle d'un chef
d'entreprise dont le souci est
l'efficacité et la mobilisation du
personnel
cette planification doit constituer pour
l'ensemble des personnels de la maison
un projet d'entreprise qui le mobilise
et qui lui permettent de savoir quel
sens à son travail et vers quel vers
quel avenir il va pour l'instant cette
nouvelle stratégie n'est qu'un voeu les
directeurs des 1000 hôpitaux publics
contre la france n'ont pas actuellement
les moyens d'être responsables de leur
budget le seul interlocuteur des
personnels hospitaliers
c'est le ministère on les voit parfois
battre de l'aspect dans la rue mais
cette fois ci ils ont marché en cortège
près d'un millier d'inspecteur de police
ont répandu à paris à l'appel du
syndicat national autonome des policiers
en civil
solitaire pour exiger du ministère de
l'intérieur les négociations sur leurs
salaires et leurs conditions de travail
la trêve des municipales aient fini leur
mandat ne les protège plus voici trois
autres hommes politiques inculpé dans la
sphère des fausses factures du sud est
après jean-pierre de péretti hier
c'était aujourd'hui au tour de jean
victor cordonnier l'ancien premier
adjoint au maire de marseille est aussi
de jean pierre roux l'ancien maire
d'avignon
dominique terre il aurait perçu 150
mille francs pour donner un avis
favorable pour la construction d'un
lycée jean pierre roux l'ancien maire
rpr la vigne on était sur la liste de
paul pelletier
le directeur de la normale il vient
d'être inculpé de corruption même chef
d'inculpation pour jean-louis geiger un
conseiller udf à la région provence côte
d'azur
les cent mille francs de pots-de-vin
auraient servi à la campagne électorale
de jean claude gaudin jean-victor
cordonnier l'adjointe ps de la ville de
marseille aurait quant à lui encaissé
150 mille francs pour faciliter un appel
d'offres
les deux autres inculpations concernent
des responsables d'une société
d'aménagement proche de jacques médecin
le maire de nice là encore selon paul
pelletier 200 mille francs auraient été
versées dans le dossier fausses factures
la prochaine échéance judiciaire devrait
concerner charles scac via le maire udf
de la scène ainsi que roland nungesser
le maire rpr de nogent sur marne jusqu'à
ce jour
tous les inculpés démentent ces
accusations il hésite et on supputait il
se lance laurent fabius s'est mis à la
disposition de son parti c'est
l'expression employée par son entourage
pour prendre la tête de la liste
socialiste aux prochaines élections
européennes le 18 juin prochain
la candidature sera officialisée par le
comité directeur du ps le 4 avril
pierre mauroy s'est engagé à la soutenir
une précision les fonctions de président
de l'assemblée nationale et deux députés
européens sont compatibles cette belle
unanimité à gauche au sein du parti
socialiste n'existe pas à droite les
diverses tendances de l'udf exprime dans
les grincements de voix et un certain
désordre
la difficulté d'être d'une coalition
objet de la discorde les européennes
bien sûr véronique sainte olive
nous décrit l'intriguent depuis trois
jours la pièce fait fureur ce n'est pas
tant à cause du texte mais de la
distribution qui est brillante
valéry giscard d'estaing c'est le père
de l'union son raisonnement est limpide
puisque on est d'accord sur le fond il
n'y a pas de raison de partir divisés
l'udf doit donc faire une liste unique
avec le rpr qui est d'accord une liste
dont giscard est sûr d'être la meilleure
tête pierre méhaignerie s'est lancé il y
a quatre jours il l'a dit il le répète
le cds fera cavalier seul aux
européennes de liste c'est mieux qu'une
dit-il en substance cela permet de
ratisser large
c'est aussi une façon pour lui de
conforter une indépendance chèrement
acquise à la rentrée parlementaire
françois léotard est le troisième homme
on se l'arrachent giscard pour sa liste
d'union
méhaignerie pour sa liste autonome
léotard préférait deux listes ses amis
madelin est longue et en veulent une le
président du prd à jouer fin pour ne pas
faire exploser son parti les personnages
tournent et retournent ils concilient à
bulle
ils font des messes basses les alliances
se nouent et se dénouent
rien n'est sûr seul peut-être simone
veil sait où elle va elle devrait
annoncer sans tarder et qu'elle est
prête à prendre la tête d'une liste il
ne lui reste plus qu'à la constituer
depuis les présidentielles
l'udf maintenait un semblant d'unité le
rendez vous européen de juin sera son
heure de vérité l'étranger maintenant le
cauchemar continue pour les chrétiens
libanais restés au pays
le cauchemar est aussi la peur que la
situation n'empire encore la nuit
dernière plus de 2000 au but syrien pour
la plupart se sont abattues sur le nord
et l'est de beyrouth bilan probable une
dizaine de morts une trentaine de
blessés
pearce r2 au bio la minute c'est le
rythme des tirs d'artillerie qui ont
martelé la nuit dernière
21 encore le réduit chrétiens qui
s'étend de beyrouth est vers le nord
l'étau syrien se resservent avec le
concours des milices musulmanes et rue
objectif le blocus de l'enclavé
chrétienne particulièrement visé le port
de jounieh à 25 km au nord de beyrouth
seule sortie vers l'extérieur pour les
chrétiens cerné de toutes parts c'est
cet homme le général aoun chef du
gouvernement chrétien qui a décidé
d'obtenir le départ des troupes
syriennes coûte que outre les morts et
les blessés qui se comptent par dizaines
la pénurie alimentaire s'est vite aussi
dans les quartiers surpeuplés les
milices chrétiennes en conflit et que
générale il ya à peine 1 - soutiennent
aujourd'hui son action
les forces libanaises sont satisfaites
de ce que réclame le général aoun c'est
à dire le retrait de toutes les forces
d'occupation étrangères non libanaises
c'est à dire les troupes syriennes
israélienne iranienne et les autres il y
a deux choix ou bien se soumettre au
fait accompli de l'occupation et de
l'amputation des deux tiers du liban et
de l'annexion de ces deux tiers à la
syrie ou bien il faut résister payer le
prix l'indépendance la liberté
les musulmans sont des malgré nous ils
soutiennent ce que nous faisons eux ils
sont muselés ils peuvent pas dire tout
ce qu'il pense mais en fait ils tirent
dessus quand même ce sont les clients
les collaborateurs de la syrie qui
l'entourent dessus c'est pas la
population civile et la majorité des
musulmans en attendant les syriens sont
toujours là décidé à rester et les
populations se terrent dans les abris
suspendus aux radios qui les informent
minute par minute du danger qui les
menace
et ce soir les duels d'artillerie ont
repris entre les deux secteurs de
beyrouth
malgré les divergences de vues entre la
france et la syrie essentiellement à
propos du liban le président syrien
assad a été officiellement invité en
france
la fièvre électorale gagne les
soviétiques ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'il s'apprête à voter mais
l'élection dimanche prochain des
représentants à la chambre des
nationalités du parlement déchaîne les
passions
les changements imprimé par mikhaïl
gorbatchev sont pris très à coeur en
tout cas par une partie de l'opinion
c'est ce que révèle un intéressant
sondage publié à la fois par le nouvel
observateur et le journal des élections
le premier sondage politique conduit par
le centre
de recherche soviétique de sociologie
près de 50% des personnes interrogées
aspirent au multipartisme à
l'occidentale et 48% plébiscitent un
homme limogé il ya quelques mois de la
direction du parti communiste de moscou
son nom boris elstine boris superstars
comme l'ont constaté à moscou gilles
rabin et jean-marie lequertier cet homme
ne peut plus faire un pas dans moscou
sans être aussitôt assailli entouré
arrêté par la foule une foule qui
l'interpellent le presse de questions
la classe et l'appelle par son prénom
boris nikolaevitch mois les six corps
ici une superstar chelem le plus
populaire du rss juste après gorbatchev
chat un chat soviétique officiel
populaire parce qu'il parle vrai avec
des mots qui reste toujours interdite
dans les discours politiques mafia
bureaucratique liminaire kobe corruption
a dû tout voir
incompétence
un parler vrai qui lui a déjà coûté cher
il a perdu son rang de premier
secrétaire du parti à moscou et il a été
exclu du bureau politique
maurice saussine est aujourd'hui le
candidat des pauvres ceux des
appartements communautaires ce dès que
quotidiennes devant des magasins presque
vide
le candidat des smicards de l'union
soviétique boris eltsine ratisse large
et il n'hésite pas à reprendre les idées
qui marchent l'écologie leur éveil
religieux
le réveil des nationalités et même la
remise en cause du dogme communiste du
parti unique
la plupart de ses supporters ne
parviendront pas à entrer pour entendre
ou eltsine et ses jugements catégorique
le bureau politique c'est une maison de
retraite pour vieillards méritants du
parti des vieillards qu'il faudra
supporter encore pendant trois ans des
militants sud sont venus apporter la
contradiction à celui qu'ils tiennent
pour un candidat en petits partis les
échanges sont violents mais démocratie
oblige
boris eltsine répondre à toutes les
questions et à toutes les attaques même
celle des provocateurs déclaré le débat
aura duré plus de six heures trois fois
plus longtemps que prévu et boris
eltsine avoue qu'il est épuisé
c'est fatiguant le débat démocratique
je ne sais pas mais être populaire chez
nous ce n'est pas la portée de tout le
monde
à ceux qui n'ont pas pu entrer et qui
sont restés quand même on vient faire un
compte rendu des débats
je reste parce que je voterai pour boris
eltsine
non un retraité de 85 roubles il ses
nuits qu'elle signe qu'on ne peut pas
vivre avec ça partout valeur candidats
des grands mères comme celle ci payent
malgré le froid et la nuit les
babouchkas montent la garde pour elle ou
re boris superstar est déjà élu boris
superstar qui selon monsieur guerre
asimov le porte-parole soviétique du
ministère des affaires étrangères crêpés
hier à paris racing dont qui fait
bientôt au figure d'opposant en union
soviétique
retournons maintenant au cambodge ce
pays trop oublié qui après les khmers
rouges
aiguisant d'occupation vietnamienne
renaît de ses cendres jean-marc il use
et philipp etter nous faisait découvrir
hier le nouveau visage de phnom penh la
capitale
accompagnons les ce soir dans les
rizières et dans les temps en pleine
campagne
ces ruines sacré de l'époque encore yen
sont celles du temple de pommes qui sort
à 50 km au sud-ouest de pneus
elle cible routinière de l'aviation
pendant la guerre américaine puis refuge
des fanatiques mer rouge après leur
éviction du pouvoir par l'armée
vietnamienne en 79 l'homme chi sort est
aujourd'hui rendue à ces bonzes et à
leurs méditations dit si on domine la
grande plaine centrale du cambodge le
panier harry et à poissons se cambodge
utile que le gouvernement de phnom penh
a soutenu par le vietnam affirme
aujourd'hui contrôlé à 90 %
c'est vrai sur les routes qui mènent à
la ville la circulation est dense
en dépit de la menace de mines khmers
rouges sur les chemins de campagne et on
république populaire du congo de chiens
en rpk le bouddhisme fait toujours
autant recette chez le paysan cambodgien
malgré les persécutions sanglantes
menées par les khmers rouges de 75 79
plus d'un million de morts nulle
inquiétude apparente non plus dans les
rizières en cette saison de repiquage du
riz
et puis ici on a très vite abandonné le
collectivisme le paysan propriétaire de
sa récolte en obtient désormais un bon
prix pour la première fois cette année
le cambodge va redécouvrir
l'autosuffisance alimentaire loi des
conférences internationales et des
luttes de factions ce qui compte pour
les paysans cambodgiens
c'est d'abord de pouvoir se rendre à son
travail en toute sécurité d'aller à la
pagode en toute liberté et bien sûr de
vendre son riz à un bon prix fort de ce
début de retour à la normale le
gouvernement de phnom penh installé au
pouvoir par les vietnamiens voilà dix
ans veut montrer aujourd'hui qu'il a su
conquérir sa propre légitimité sur le
terrain économique ici spectacle nouveau
cambodge d'après 75 une maison en
construction en pleine campagne
cette paysanne explique que sa famille a
investi 10 ans d'économies est le fruit
de la vente de quelques bijoux
là on replante pour la première fois des
palmiers à sucre il ne produiront que
dans trente ans manifestement ici la
population paris que la paix s'est
installé pour durer
question mais une fois rentrés dans leur
quartier les troupes du puissant vietnam
l'armée les milices de la république
populaire de caen putsch air pourront
elles seules empêcher le retour des
sanguinaires khmers rouges
les boat people vietnamiens continuent
de mourir en mer de chine 130 d'entre
eux se sont noyés leurs bateaux de
fortune éventrée par un pétrolier
japonais
eric père ouverture d'une enquête au
japon à la suite de la noyade
accidentelle de 130 boat people
vietnamiens
selon la chaîne de télévision nippone
nhk la barre qu'ils se trouvent et 165
réfugiés auraient été s'est heurtée par
un superpétrolier japonais version
confirmée par l'un des trente cinq
rescapés
les propriétaires du pétrolier affirment
quant à eux que l'embarcation a chaviré
alors que l'équipage tenter de venir en
aide aux boat people
pas de containers mais un bloc de béton
l'objet métalliques repérés mardi par
sonar n'était pas le container en
fermant cinq tonnes de lin dan ce
pesticides hautement toxiques
les recherches repartent donc de zéro
mais le coup de vent annoncé pour demain
dans la manche seront les investigations
très difficile
réponse négative de rome à la demande
d'audience de monseigneur gaillot les
vagues d'hébreu surnommé par certains
l'enfant terrible de l'épiscopat avait
demandé un entretien jean paul 2 pour
s'expliquer sur ses différentes prises
de position
monseigneur gaillot regrette ce refus
tout en réaffirmant sa communion entière
avec l'église dernière minute nouveau
rebondissement dans la sphère des
fausses factures du sud est ce dont je
vous parlais tout à l'heure
une information pour corruption a été
ouverte aujourd'hui contre le chef de la
section financière du srpj de marseille
selon l'un de ses collègues policiers
auraient été sollicités comme d'autres
dans cette affaire pour qu'une société
de travaux publics ne soit pas mise en
cause
on les appelle les tagueurs la nuit ils
rasent les murs équipés de feutre ou de
bombes à peintures
il affectionne les wagons du métro ce ne
sont plus des graffitis disent les
amateurs c'est de l'art brut brut peut
être mais cher pour la ratp qui estime
que le nettoyage l'écoutent quelques 35
millions de francs par an agnès poirier
et bernie mairie où se sont fondus dans
la nuit pour les suit dernier train
vient de passer la nuit leur appartient
le grand frisson
attention danger d'abord signalé son
passage marqué son territoire
alors on tag c'est à dire on signe
illisible pour tous les initiés
reconnaîtront
et puis ils attaquent la fresque et la
brûlure comme ils disent leur signature
stylisé et un personnage qui seront vues
dès l'aube par des dizaines de milliers
de banlieusards du jeu ce qu'on nous
voit ans qui partout et qu'on avait un
père c'est parce que vous ne la plupart
d'entre nous ont envie de passer ça
s'appelle aussi dégradation bien
tribulations avec des femmes
d'aujourd'hui la chasse aux graffiteurs
est ouverte
ras-le-bol des tags qui défigurent les
stations et sur les trains affirme-t-on
à la sncf et à la ratp
il en annonce plus de répression c'est
plus de nettoyage
je donnais un chiffre qui est le chiffre
de 10 millions de nous avons bien
entendu que nous avons dépensé l'année
dernière en 1988 ne pour faire du
nettoyage aussi bien être avec des
guerres mais c'est insuffisant puisque
cette année en 89
on voit bien qu'il faudra dépenser
beaucoup plus que ça courageux les
tagueurs mais ils sont déjà partout
ramsès époux façon passer des graffitis
à la musique qu'ils ont créé saï saï
leur emblème c'est un tag
ils ont à peine 18 ans ils veulent que
ce qu'ils appellent leur art soit
respectée les voisins quand une maj la
musique qui disent oh qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bruit c'est de la musique
ou bien qu'est ce que c'est que cette c1
puis sur mur pas la saloperie c'est la
peinture
certains graffiteurs sont même très
demandé olivier mégatonnes par exemple
qui peignait sur les palissades de
chantier aujourd'hui rebaptisée artistes
aérosols il décore des devantures de
magasins et à dessiner le graphisme de
la carte jeune d'harcourt lui n'a pas eu
cette chance pour avoir pas une fresque
sur un point la sncf on lui réclame 750
mille francs de dommages et intérêts je
suis pas conscients de pabx de crainte
de l'accord parce que je pense de mire
même si je ne demande pas aux prophètes
pour moi c'est pas un délit pour nous je
ne cherche pas détruit
vandal ou artistes que vont ils devenir
la prison peut-être pas certains d'entre
eux sont déjà dans les galeries gare
avant de nous quitter retourneront
brièvement en corse avec ses toutes
dernières images que françois joly vient
de nous faire parvenir
vous le voyez la bagarre continue à
bastia entre les manifestants et les crs
devant la préfecture
des bagarres donc provoqué au cours de
la journée par l' annonce à bastien que
la négociation que le syndicat attendait
pour demain avec les représentants du
gouvernement et bien que cette
négociation cette réunion n'aurait pas
lieu
les incidents continuent donc ce soir à
bastia très vite je vous donne encore
les rapports du quarté de d'auteuil
aujourd'hui à l'arrivée le 12 le 9
annoncée car c'est que nous avons là le
12 le 9 et le 10 5 francs dans l'ordre
rapporte 6325 francs et dans un ordre
différent 1208 francs 50 dans un instant
laurent cabrol va vous parler du temps
de demain vos autres rendez vous avec
l'information ce soir édition spéciale à
22h30 au seuil on nous parlera des
erreurs médicales et henri sannier vous
présentera le dernier journal vers
minuit demain matin l'invité de gérard
morin aux 4 vérités
le secrétaire d'état chargé du plan
lionel stoléru très bonne soirée sur
antenne 2 avec le bon plaisir à demain
20 heures